hey guys we're gonna talk about the
seven recommended supplements on a
ketogenic diet and intermittent fasting
plan okay first one I'm going to
recommend is minerals you want potassium
magnesium sodium and calcium those are
electrolytes and the trace minerals why
because minerals help reduce insulin
resistance and it puts you into
fat-burning a lot better plus these
minerals are alkaline which offsets some
of the uric acid buildup that comes with
a ketogenic diet to lessen the chance of
getting gout or uric acid kidney stones
number two vitamin b1 this is essential
in the adaptation from sugar burning
into fat burning also it's great to
relieve stress vitamin b3 this is really
good for lowering cholesterol that is
coming out of the fat cells out through
the liver and it's also good to support
the liver in general a vitamin b5 is
another key B vitamin that's essential
in the adaptation to fat burning okay
and if you're deficient in b5 for b1 you
may notice more fatigue keto flu kiddo
rash any of those symptoms
number five Ataman a which is also
essential in dealing with insulin
resistance and you would get vitamin A
in cod liver oil grass-fed cheese you
can get in grass-fed liver if I don't
really personally like liver but it's in
there and egg yolks number six vitamin D
and I recommend the d3 version this is
really good for insulin resistance
improving that it's also in cod liver
oil egg yolks in fact if you consume cod
liver oil you'll get a 50/50 split
vitamin A and vitamin D so you can kill
two birds with one stone
and number seven choline which is
essential for getting fat off the liver
okay so I recommend doing electrolyte
powder for the minerals so I recommend
nutritional yeast for b1 b3 b5 and it
even has choline okay I have a version
that's non fortified it's in a tablet
form with added b12 so you have
electrolyte powder nutritionally use in
cod liver oil and if you really have a
fatty liver you can add choline in
addition to
the cooling that's in here to strip off
the fat from the liver alright thanks
for watching
hey before you go definitely sign up for
my free keto course I put a link down
below it's on messenger in Facebook but
it will give you all the basics it's
very quick it's like three or four
videos and it's free check it out